okay so after watching kick-ass I really
started to think to myself why hasn't
someone dressed up like a superhero in
fought crime so I looked into it turns
out kick-ass had it wrong people have
and they do oh yes they do
sorta I found a group called the Black
Monday Society based in Salt Lake City
Utah where people dress up and fight
crime in Salt Lake City Utah
yeah those Mormons can be real Rascals
but then I kept searching and there's a
whole network of superheroes and
something called the superhero world
registry never heard of that because I
just hadn't it kind of blows my mind I
mean some people look like they're
really trying to take it seriously and
other people just look like they're
[ __ ] around and LARPing yes I know
what LARPing means well then you start
looking into it just when you're ready
to take these people kind of seriously
some [ __ ] dresses up and makeup and
he gets on camera he's all like I'm here
to send a message to the superhero
registration you see for years gee mom
I'm talking to my friends lame and I
kind of takes it from a bunch of people
dressing in costumes trying to make a
difference and makes it feel like a
bunch of junior high students screwing
around the Joker
not only the most overused costume on
Halloween but also the supervillain
underground and by supervillain
underground I mean internet trolls with
cameras and makeup but there are people
who genuinely want to make this
superhero thing like a real movement
they really want this superhero thing to
take off and become as common it's like
Vegemite in Australia ice in the Arctic
AIDS in Africa I kid but I'm not gonna
lie Africa really got the short stick
when it comes to being famous or
something I personally think this
superhero thing is really awesome but I
want to see something really big happen
you know
I mean generally speaking right now they
give like sandwiches and toothbrushes to
homeless people but I want to see like a
mob boss gets strung up on a spotlight
see a semi get flipped in the street
alright last Batman reference I swear
well see the Batmobile like block a
rocket from wasting the DEA come on you
wanna see that too I mean come on I
would dress up like a superhero that
would be awesome
what did you do today oh I just faxed my
boss last month's numbers and boring day
am i fact my boss those numbers any
broken motor space on my knee so yes it
may be on a smaller scale than in the
comics but we do have our share of
eccentric suiting up to stop crime in
the streets so what do you guys think of
there's just a few crazies out there
playing cops and robbers or one small
step for man one giant leap for the
Avengers or the JLA to you DC people
comment below let me know what you think
and I've also put the link to the
superhero registry in the box below
check it out it kind of blows your mind
ledo's